make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and i was gonna pick up with uh
batman joker war the newest installment
of the joker war but we're gonna
sidetrack from that for a second we're
gonna cover the origin of punchline so i
feel like this is probably one of the
more interesting stories right and kind
of what i think a lot of batman fans
want to know right like what's the story
of punchline how did punchline become
the joker's new girlfriend right
so this comes out of the joker 80th
anniversary
100 page super spectacular one shot and
and comic books do this for those of you
guys who are new comics do this from
time to time right they'll have like a
super popular character that's been
around for a really really long time and
they'll do like a one-shot comic to
celebrate that character like when
action comics reached issue number 1000
they did like a whole bunch of different
stories just celebrating the history of
superman and it was just like this
this great big huge amalgamation of
different stories from different writers
and different artists and different
things like that it was cool it was it
was pretty awesome and this one's more
or less the same way but what this does
here and this is actually a cool little
tribute
it picks up in a place called snyder
college of course named for scott snyder
because aside from dennis o'neill and
neil adams he's probably the single most
influential batman writer in the history
of the character to be honest with you
guys you know like it's it's kind of
nuts given like the work he did
the fact that like when new 52 launched
that it brought in a whole new wave of
batman readers and the story was written
so well and it's probably one of the
most celebrated batman stories of all
time right one of the most celebrated
batman runs that's ever been written so
it makes sense but they would just be
kind of a tribute here plus i'm pretty
sure james kenyon and scott snyder are
friends so
this picks up basically with with what's
more or less just called kind of a
make your you know celebrate your
superhero day is really what this is and
you've got this guy dean bob who's
talking to this young woman right this
girl named alexis and the reason why is
because of the fact that in
in really within the last little while
there was an attack in gotham city where
a girl named sarah had lost you know
some some people that she knew and this
was all you know as a result of
a joker attack right a gas attack and
the reason why this matters is because
unlike everybody else who's basically
celebrating their favorite heroes you
know celebrating you know the flash or
batman or green lantern or superman or
something like that alexis has a joker
shirt on
you know she's celebrating the joker
which is wildly provocative right and
it's not simply just her wearing a shirt
like she's kind of obsessed with the
character of the joker right she's
obsessed with everything about him right
she's got posters
she's got like all kinds of drawings
artistic renderings the funny thing
about this is that some of these
drawings are are a combination of things
right so you've got
an alex ross depiction of the joker
which is up there uh you've got the
joker from the killing joke you've got
like just different versions of his
character over the years
that are shown now this this is this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's like
an incontinuity thing just kind of a
cool little tribute by the artist of the
comic right is really all it is but
the idea is that the dean comes down
here tell you know telling her hey like
this is kind of a problem you have to
take this this whole
you got to take this shirt off right
this is kind of offensive to people and
the reality is that where he he claimed
that he came down here as a friend
she kind of calls it right off the bat
and it's like no you didn't come down
here as a friend
you came down here because you're scared
of this shirt you're scared of what it
represents and you know that it's
dangerous right what you want me to do
is to go out into the quad right kind of
usually on universities you have what's
called a quad which is like a great big
huge park area more or less inside the
inside the university where most people
hang out at and she's like you want me
to go down there and you want me to like
let out some
some tear-jerking cry about how i'm
maladjusted and this shirt is just some
outward manifestation of the inner
turmoil that i'm struggling with because
i really can't figure my place out and
i'm just crying out for help and all
that kind of stuff and she's like no
that's not the case at all that's
not what this is it's not that i'm
maladjusted it's not that i'm i'm crying
out for help that's not at all what's
going on here
your concern here is that you have a
daedric a dangerous student who believes
in something dangerous that's operating
right under your nose and in the midst
of all that she literally like blows
smoke in his face
and when that happens of course he you
know kind of waves it out of the way and
then kind of starts talking to her and
as he's talking to her begins to kind of
start laughing a little bit right and
he's like what in the world did you do
to me and she's like well i got the
recipe off the internet and i didn't
know if it really works or i didn't know
if it was gonna work at all you wouldn't
believe how many different chemicals it
that it takes in order to make it but i
have a pretty good teacher right looking
at the closet you know she's like i have
a pretty good teacher so it's like okay
got a laptop stored in there or
something like that but
you know she's like for for me like the
paralytic is finally setting in but
don't fight any of it right i want to
get all of this on camera and the reason
why is because that girl sarah has been
playing up her whole tragedy for likes
right she's been playing it all up on
social media she's trying to get the
world to feel bad for her you know
how crappy of a person do you have to be
to take your own personal tragedy and
throw it out there on the internet not
because of the fact that you actually
care about the people who who had bad
things done to them not because you care
about them as people because you know
that sympathy story is gonna get you
more likes it's gonna get you more
followers right you're doing it just to
manipulate people how crappy of a person
do you have to be in order to pull that
off but if what she wants
is horror then i will bring her [ __ ] if
what she wants
is suffering then i will bring her
suffering if what she wants is real pain
that she can put on the internet then
that's what i will give her i'm going to
dress you up like a victim of the joker
and i'm going to put you in her bed and
so that when she comes in
she's not going to be posting on social
media for likes she's going to
experience
nightmares day after day after day she's
going to see your face in her sleep and
she'll never catch a moment's piece i
will give her what it is that she wants
i'll give her
what it is that she's asking for even if
she doesn't know that she's asking for
it right and that's what's kind of crazy
here
because this girl like alexis she's just
dark and that's kind of what she says
she's like this is all your fault you
asked for this right you and your
generation asked for this you grew
you kept telling us as we could grow up
we could be anything we wanted to and
you left us some kind of half-assed
world of living we could be anything we
wanted to what you never considered is
it some of us
don't want to be the good guys we don't
want to be the ones who save the world
we want to be the ones who destroy it we
want to be the ones who tear it down
and build it into something better and
something new now that's that's actually
an amazing point to make right because
there's certain assumptions that are
made right i kind of sidetracked this
from it for us you know for a second
there's certain assumptions that are
made right and it's kind of like these
unwritten assumptions right like when we
tell our kids you can be anything you
want we tell them that under the
assumption that what they want to be
is something good right like a
contributing member of society and
that's not an unreasonable assumption to
make nobody says you know hey like you
know i told my child they could be
anything and so they became like a
sociopath like that's not really
you know what what we aspire to what we
aspire to is i told my child
you know they could be anything and so
they became batman that's what we're
talking about right just like awesome
things in the real world i would right
like
it's like that meme right they said i
could be anything so i became i became
batman
like that's that's it's it's cool right
it's a it's a cool little thing it's
it's it's nice and so because of that
you know this is kind of the opposite
side it's people
basically getting what they asked for
just not exactly what they were asking
for right like she was raised and told
you could be anything you want to but
the other part of this is there's kind
of a darker side to this
the way she sees the world is a darker
place right the world sucks the world's
crappy the world's full of terrible
people right if humanity wanted to get
it together humanity would have gotten
it together by now but humanity hasn't
right and so humanity is inherently bad
people just don't care about other
people regardless of what they say right
they say one thing they do another and
so because of that like it's important
to just rip it all down
and that's where she became enamored
with the joker right like the whole
world is built on this ridiculous joke
and she's the punchline right hence
where she got her name from and that's
when he kind of starts basically
succumbing to the joker toxin or at
least this basic toxin in the most
intense way and then from there she kind
of chimes in and she says okay like like
speaking to a person we can't see
if what you wanted was for me to prove
that i'm not some fan girl right if what
you wanted was for me to prove that i'm
actually serious about wanting to become
your henchman then here's the proof
here's the proof that i'm ready to get
serious and we find out that in that
closet
is the joker himself right by some
manner in some means
she managed to get a hold of the joker
but she managed to get a hold of this
guy and this guy was intrigued by her he
was interested in her now we all kind of
know that at the end of the day she's a
means to an end right that's really all
punchline is she's just a way for joker
to like achieve a goal or to get back at
batman or even to get back at harley
quinn right the joker's schemes don't
make sense to anybody but himself but
regardless of what his motivations are
she got his attention and she was
interesting enough that he didn't kill
her so because of that you know she's
kind of like you know what what comes
next is going to be wild
right like it's it's going to be it's
it's going to be insane it's going to be
serious and the joker's response is no
it's not going to be serious my dear
punchline what comes next is going to be
hilarious
right and so what this does is it
basically kind of bookends to everything
that starts with the batman story with
the joker war right well really even
before that the introduction of
punchline and all that kind of stuff so
in terms of our batman playlist we'll
probably position it up there uh you
know basically
ahead of everything else so you can kind
of go into it knowing who punchline is
and having that whole story uh you'll
kind of have to ignore the segments that
we that we were talking about in the
previous videos where like we don't know
anything about punchline so maybe i'll
just leave it here i don't know i'll
figure it out
but if you guys are new here the
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah i
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
in this house
[Music]
in this town
[Music]
oh